للمره الاولى منذ ثمانيه اشهر تمكن عمال
الاغاثه من الدخول الى خرسون محملين
بالمساعدات الانسانيه الامم المتحده سلمت
اليوم امدادات تكفي لمساعده اكثر من سته
الاف مدنيه بعد ثلاثه ايام من السعاده
القوات الاوكرانيه للسيطره على المدينه
وشامله القافله الانسانيه الطعام والماء
ومستلزمات النظافه والادوات المنزليه
الضروريه بما فيها الاغطيه الحراريه
والمصابيح الشمسيه المراكز الصحيه في
المدينه ستتلقى ايضا ادويه لعلاج اكثر من
1000 مريض خلال الاشهر المقبله جهات
الاكرانيه المختصه تعمل الى جانبي ازاله
الالغام على اعاده امدادات الغاز
والاتصالات ويكافح سكان خرسون طبعا الذين
يصل عددهم حاليا ل 80,000 شخص لتلبيه
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه في ظل نقص حاد في
المياه هو المواد الغذائيه وبالتامن مع
توزيع المساعدات حتى حاكم مدينه خي السكان
على تجنب الاماكن المزدحمه محذرا من
تفجيرات محتمله
[تصفيق]
ليش